je voulais vous faire une vidéo sur
périscope parce que ces derniers temps
il ya pas mal de choses qui se passent
sur l'appli qui sont assez assez triste
le plus triste c'était il ya deux jours
quand une fille s'est donné la mort mais
avant ça il ya eu même je sais pas des
jeunes qui disait voilà au bout de
cinquante personnes qui se connectent à
l'application on se met à frapper des
gens dans la rue et donc il ya messi
fait de taper à bordeaux je crois sinon
il ya eu des employés des sphères qui
ont dit deux employés qui étaient là à
dire s'il ya tant de personnes ont
bousillé ce téléphone l'a donc voilà il
ya pas mal de choses qui se passent sur
l'application et donc j'essaie de
comprendre pourquoi pourquoi il ya ces
trucs là je pense que alors dans toute
cette vidéo là je vais pas faire ma
réflexion par rapport à ce qui s'est
passé il ya deux jours parce que je
considère que c'est un cas à part parce
que c'est un cas plus graves jeu plus
m'intéresser aux petits aux délinquants
quoi un petit peu donc les mecs de sfr
où les mecs qui est qui ont frappé
d'autres gens dans la rue et je pense
que ce qui est recherché en tout cas ce
qui a l'air d'être recherché c'est un
peu l'audience tu vois quand on dit à
partir de tant de personnes je fais si
ou alors j'ai même vu des trucs genre à
partir de tant de personnes je monte mes
seins etc
il ya une recherche d'audience enfin je
sais pas si c'est ce qu'on recherche
en tout cas tout se passe comme si on
cherchait sa hockey et j'aimerais
comprendre pourquoi pourquoi on
recherche l'audience je pense qu'on a
vus ensemble avec la vidéo sur hegel si
vous l'avez pas vu je voulais mais là
que finalement la reconnaissance de
l'autre tout cas le fait que l'autre on
nous voit ça ça nous rapporte à notre
propre existence
donc c'est une manière de se sentir
exister il ya ça et il ya aussi la
célébrité je pense que le mode de vie
des célébrités se voit et ça peut donner
envie
et puis même si on peut vouloir passer à
la télé à la radio c'est pas pour rien
qu'on utilise le mot percée par exemple
quand on dit à percer c'est comme s'il y
avait une sorte de plafond invisible et
qu'on arrivait à passer au travers ça
donc c'est une forme en fait de réussite
dans le langage en tout cas donc c'est
peut-être ce qui est recherché aussi et
vu qu'en plus ça a l'air de plus en plus
accessible parce que les gens qui sont
célèbres bas sont un peu comme comme
vous et moi tu vois de plus en plus on
se sent proche d'eux notamment avec des
outils comme etc
c'est un chat et compagnie vu qu'on se
sent proche d'eux on se dit pourquoi pas
tu vas peut-être que ça peut ça peut les
attirer plus et en plus qui a derrière
la volonté suprême je pense qu'ils se
cache là c'est celle de l'immortalité
c'est celle de passe est passé dans
l'histoire quoi c'est un peu comme
eurostat qui avait brûlé le temple
d'artémis à ephèse qui est une merveille
du monde antique
et quand on lui a demandé pourquoi il
l'a fait c'était pour la célébrité
il l'a clairement dit après je pense que
c'est pas la seule raison qui peut
pousser à faire de la merde sur
périscope je pense que parfois c'est
juste un prétexte
c'est comme quand tu t'en brouille avec
un mec dans la rue et il y avait des
gars qui se font frapper juste parce que
il l'a mal regardé
ouais je vais donner une droite il m'a
mal regardé ah non en fait avait juste
envie de frapper et tu as pris comme
prétexte le fait que le mec t'as mal
regardé soit mais tu as et plus ont une
recherche de prétexte qu'une motivation
en soi alors du coup est ce que tout ça
fait de périscopes un outil de merde je
pense pas ça me fait penser à la vidéo
de john rachid il ya quelques semaines
où il ya quelques mois qui a fait une
vidéo sur du périscope pour dire à quel
point c'était 7 est naze et qui avait
aucun contenu culturel ou intéressant et
c'est en fait c'est faux genre par
exemple il ya une semaine ou deux il ya
une journaliste qui a fait un live
périscope depuis la corée du nord
inédit incroyable sa première fois qu'on
voyait genre
la corée du nord en live sur internet en
tout cas moi je t'apprends fois que je
voyais j'étais pas le seul où il ya eu
la nuit debout aussi genre y'a un mec a
fait des télescopes sur lui de boue qui
ont battu les records en france
d'affluence sur périscope c'était dingue
et même dans une moindre mesure bas mais
là il périscope à moi souvent je fais de
la lecture genre schopenhauer des trucs
comme ça où on lit un texte ensemble et
on explique et franchement ça on passe
un bon quoi ou alors l'autre fois
c'était sur des notions de marketing
enfin je trouve ça intéressant ps comme
c'était un outil du coup ça dépend ce
qu'on en fait et du coup vu que c'est un
outil ça c'est intéressant parce qu'il
permet de révéler certaines choses je
pense que premièrement et c'est un des
trucs le plus important il me permet de
voir qu'il ya un manque d'écouté quoi si
tu as des personnes qui se mettent sur
ps coop en recherche d'attention etc
c'est peut-être parce que ces personnes
là elles peuvent pas s'exprimer d'une
manière plus simple et que finalement
elles sont c'est des personnes qui sont
isolées est ce que ça révèle pas un
besoin de célébrités parce que la
célébrité nous paraît plus en plus
accessible aussi et je trouve aussi
intéressant de voir qu'en fait on
nourrit notre ennui
par quoi que ce soit quoi genre tu as
des mecs qui sont hyper balèze qui te
font des scénaristes est ou qui sont des
séries de ouf
des films de ouf des albums incroyable
avec plus d'artistes etc
et toi tu préfères t'ennuyer sur
périscope ben c'est assez révélateur
d'un truc quand même tu vois ça te
montre à quel point le voyeurisme a une
place importante et c'est pas forcément
négatif c'est pas forcément négatif
parce que le voyeurisme
si tu prends le truc à la base c'est
quand même la curiosité pour les autres
si la curiosité pour autrui tu vois moi
c'est un peu ça aussi qui me pousse à
essayer de comprendre comment marche le
monde comment marchent les hommes etc
c'est un peu de ça tu vois on a pris une
manière de faire évidemment mais je peux
pas blâmer quelqu'un qui a ce côté
voyeuriste
je peux pas le faire parce que je l'est
aussi en fait mais d'une autre manière
un autre un autre problème que périscope
met en avant ce qui en fait le live
c'est un métier tu vois gérer un live
c'est un métier je pense que c'est très
facile de se trouver devant des gens de
vouloir les
les divertir tu vois et ont du coup
[ __ ] il faut que je trouve un truc fou
seront un truc à faire un truc qui
médiature et c'est beaucoup plus facile
et immédiat de faire du mal que de faire
du bien donc je pense que c'est ça c'est
un point qui est critique dans la
gestion de périscope du coup la question
qu'on peut se poser c'est est ce qu'on
aurait commis les mêmes actes sans le
périscope et je parle pas du suicide
parce que pour moi c'est beaucoup plus
complexe mais là je parle des autres
actes de josé parler vite fait et donc
est ce qu'on aurait commis ces actes
sans périscope et si la réponse est non
est-ce que périscope et responsable et
bien en fait pour moi périscope n'est
pas responsable tu as tu eu c'est c'est
périscope n'importe qui peut y aller
c'est le sait le principe c'est comme si
tu avais un village et tu mettais une
scène au milieu et genre n'importe qui
peut monter sur la scène il ya
différentes scènes pour qu'on puisse le
faire en même temps extra et donc les
gens passaient s'arrête et regarde et
c'est à toi c'est un mec c'est de la
merde tu vas pas en vouloir à la scène
tout ce que je veux dire ça n'a pas de
sens en fait ça n'a pas de sens
ayrault ce stade pour faire son incendie
il n'a pas eu besoin de périscopes tu
vois ce que je veux dire il ya des
choses qui sont incroyables affaires et
périscope et oui oui effectivement
aujourd'hui il ya pas trop de culture il
n'y a pas de trop de divertissement de
qualité pour l'instant sur les scop mais
parce que c'est le début c'est c'est une
plate forme qui vient de se créer genre
ça met du temps à mûrir quoi c'est comme
sur youtube plus on avance dans le temps
et plus on a des trucs hyper niche hyper
pointue des chaînes de vulgarisation de
trucs tu adores il ya des chaînes de
zététique par exemple quand tu agences
et un haut niveau tu vois je voulais
quand même vous exprimer ça parce que je
trouve que dans les médias il ya très
peu en fait deux défenseurs un petit peu
de l'application alors que moi je pense
qu'il ya c'est un truc incroyable
il ya énormément de choses à faire avec
c'est un superbe outil et voilà comme
tous les outils qu'on met aux mains de
l'humanité et ben il ya des trucs qui
sont dégueulasses avec et
mais c'est pas de la faute de l'outil
encore une fois c'est juste que ça
révèle des choses sur nous sur notre
humanité et ça révèle des problèmes
qu'on a peut-être pas forcément envie de
voir en rapport avec avec notre nature
je pense que vous avez compris mon point
c'était juste une petite vidéo très
rapide de réflexion à voix haute
parce que ben ça m'a fait travailler un
petit peu cette histoire du coup je vais
résumer ça en un seul tweet ps coop
n'est que ce que l'on en fait ils
révèlent des caractères propres à nous
il rend une forme de faiblesse plus
facile est visible merci d'avoir regardé
n'hésitez pas à donner vos théorique vos
impressions ce que vous pensez dans les
commentaires je suis sûr qu'à des gens
qui pensent que par exemple périscope et
responsable donc n'hésitez pas à donner
vos arguments et a expliqué pourquoi etc
et voilà voilà
on se revoit bientôt et je tapais sur un
coup de fil mais j'avais envie terre
cette vidéo donc voilà je me remets soit
sur le coup de fil ciao